oh they're just talking about Koreans
duplicitas is treacherous Behavior oh
Koreans wa whoo wo Where Are You Korean
yeah I'm just
[Laughter]
[Music]
kidding all right so we got a little
special something from NE shark they
released an article that points out the
10 Asian stereotypes that need to go
what so what we're going to do is go
through each of them and try to small
dick yeah that's number one we got to
get rid of that get that [__] out of
here that's killing my cred how about
non-verbal this hey yo nonverbal I want
to hear those no no we have to guess we
have to guess that's the game small
penis has to be on there small penis
definitely is on there which one has to
go you know what's funny math I feel
like I feel like that's not on here oh
wait well I guess kind of that's a
[__] list I'll tell you one that's
not working what if everyone thinks we
know [__] karate why do we keep
getting beat up wait you don't know
karate know then they keep going to our
neighborhoods and beating up our
grandparents and [__] no I have no idea
that stereotype don't work yeah it's
generational karate is what we need to
be teaching so um let's go through each
of them and uh see if we agree yeah
number one we're not all auto mechanics
is that a thing no I just made that one
that was so not true I've never heard
auto
mechanics I was like that was a pretty
good one we can keep that one number one
is uh the the idea of the model minority
you guys know about that oh we're
totally the model minority though so
keep that are you proud of that one no
Nick is I think there's a bright side to
that one in a way right wait NE shark
wants that to go yeah cuz aren't they
the model
minority yeah I feel like they're the
ones that like kind of represent that
model they are the like they're pretty
clean aren't they I like they are like
the I went to a UC this is what I do
mommy daddy you know like what the [__]
that's that's almost like saying stop
looking at me respectable yeah wait why
is that a bad thing though like yeah
what's the reason bad I I think the bad
part of model minority is like Asians
are kind of expected to just keep their
head down and work and I'm okay with
that it's um it's the expectation of of
grouping all Asians together as like a
monolithic group instead of like the
diversity that like oh this guy might
not fit that whole agenda or that whole
image but he's still a good person this
is this is this is why you guys are
stupid all right who me or them no the
people that don't want this stereotype
all right okay let's hear it we could be
like other cultures that have horrible
ones like thieves or a bunch of
prostitutes or whatever well actually we
do get the prostitute one like gypsies
they always get the [__] people like
oh you gypsies always coming into the
town and stealing and [__] for us it's
oh they always coming in here doing math
homework let that be you take cumans
everywhere you take advantage of The
Stereotype don't [__] let it you know
I could be in a gang one day and then
tomorrow I'll put on a bow tie and then
they don't even know I agree a joke cuz
if we have that stereotype right let's
say crime happens at a liquor store yeah
there Asian dude and a black dude cops
come hey you get the [__] on the ground
but the Asian guy could have stole this
[__] y but they're like I get to be
protected by it I like that I like that
used it yeah I would say it's more
beneficial for us than that keep that
one I like that all right okay that one
kept got it'll keep it number of course
the degener saying this number two is
the the idea of the Perpetual Foreigner
the [__] is that oh like you'll never be
an American exactly yeah you'll never be
an American that's a stereotype yeah
it's a stereotype that like even though
you've lived here like some Japanese
people are like Sixth Gen or some [__]
and then they'll still get looked at
like oh you might assume you don't speak
English exactly that one I would
say bye-bye by bye-bye how you going to
stop that though my head cuz it's like
it's outside perspective anyway right I
mean I'm not going to lie sometimes I
look like at an Asian person I'm like
not not expecting them to speak for real
for real for real like some Asians are
so [__] Asian well also how many of
us are first gen here that's what I
saying is population wise most Asians
are immigrants yeah that's what I'm
saying so until we're like two more
Generations in I get it that would that
this is going to disappear to be honest
everyone here though if I looked at you
I would assume you speak English but cuz
we're all first gen though like all of
our parents though probably still
immigrated here but I want to say like
when we're grandparents this is not
going to exist anymore you would maybe
not speak English yeah the most out of
everyone no I would say you really yeah
I think so too ears that's what I
thought the ears the Chinese ears sing
she said you got Chinese ears dude I got
Chinese ears for sure these are Chinese
stop looking them like that bro I
thought they're Brazilian I thought
cauliflower was a Brazilian thing
cauliflower was only grown in Brazil she
said what generation Japanese American
are you I'm second but I have family
members that are like fourth or fifth
damn he's feudal yeah yeah that's pretty
that's pretty heavy all right what about
the idea of yellow Peril do you know
what that is that yellow Peril is like
that irrational fear that like Asians
are going to move to a place and that's
just going to become a new Asia that's
literally what happens that happens
exactly what happens that's literally
what happen look at San Gabriel Valley I
know why is that the fear because when
Asians come into a neighborhood they
[__] clean it up they make malls they
make hella good food yeah you know think
we're a little biased but in the case of
Vancouver let's just look at that guess
maybe we might be biased the people that
moved into Vancouver they did yeah it's
a nice place but it's also now too
expensive for the locals too bad
[__] everyone else got to do
better no I'm just saying locally all
right Mony Park was a [__] show when we
when we were growing up here and the
income stat was low the school system
was low and then um now it's like one of
top tier they have high they have
[__] good grades whatever you know
what I don't like though I don't like
[__] Chinese tour
buses wait are we clapping yeah I agree
put that on the list can where like 40
Chinese people pile out of like a t yeah
it's like it's a nice peaceful City I
don't mind if people come here to
[__] live here and settle down but
it's a nice PE peaceful City you see a
Chinese tour bus pull up 40 Moms come
out start farting and [__] blowing
their [__] snot on the ground with
them Chinese manners sh they got no
personal space so they cut in line and
[__] oh that that [__] pisses me off
they cut in line you got to say
something they the whole line and then
they just go all the way to the front
and say excuse me that's yellow per old
Asians at the airport that's yellow pero
that's yellow perel all right how about
this one this one's kind of a newer one
um the coid
starter well we deserve that one wait
whoa whoa we there's different Asians
all of us are Chinese all right we're
all Chinese I've never gotten Co and I'm
proud of no way really wow how' you guys
do it good job how do I do it fizer
didn't go out no I was out damn starter
strong immune systems I'll say get rid
of that one yeah they're patient zero
all right all right which is worse any
bat eater or Co starter which one Co
starter is worst because bat eating is
funny I mean I mean if bat bats were a
actual food I would eat it so I would
say Co
started I was the co
starter he he got us all Co oh this
[__] for uh I think it was the
Mike Tyson Roy Jones junr boxing fight I
had like 20 of our friends come over and
then I was making steak and I gave 20
people yeah cuz the way this fool makes
steak is
he'll [__] and he'll pick it up with his
fingers be like Joe you got to try
there's a [__] bomb and you'll be
feeding us and [__] and the next day in
the group text everyone's like yo I'm
feeling kind of funny everyone good like
I can't taste my
food that's true how about this one
Fouch is the real Co starter for [__]
that guy the the um the dog or cat eater
that's a funny one though you want to
keep that one it's true it's true people
in Korea still be eating it they be
eating that [__] but a lot of people in
other countries [__] eat dogs too
it's more of an accessibility thing is I
remember being like 12 and having the
the brain knowledge to be like in a
third third world country where you
can't afford food I do not blame you for
eating a dog yeah they eat rats
everything but they act like we're
[__] we got a [__] Kentucky Fried
dog in in China or some [__] if we were
going to go to the best place to eat it
it would probably be in asiac dog we
don't eat that [__] dog if you want to
get some high L do thec puy I think we
we can do away with this because people
think we all eat it
okay I would never you guys I was
offered and I said no I only I could do
it bro if I was over there and this was
like we've been eating like this for
centuries I would try it I'll eat a
[__] horse dick before I eat a dog
but it's it's a different breed like
they actually breed it to eat it it's
not like Pomeranians or anything like
wag you i' rather eat a Pomeranian no
I'll try it I think the only thing I
would not try is like human meat oh I
eat a human before dog what if you had
to get your arm amputated or some [__]
would you eat yourself in in a survival
setting and I have no no not survival
like let's say you just you go to the
hospital they're like we got to remove
your arm and then at the end they're
like do you want your arm he would taste
so bad dude he has you would taste
bad that is logically weird there's ink
in it the doctor's like hey eat it eat
it I've heard that's happened I read the
story some lady got her like what some
part of her body amputated and she asked
to take it with her and they're like I
mean it's your arm like take it and she
[__] cooked it and ate it she slow
cooked it that's probably how you would
do it though slow like you do it for 12
hours what if you like it and then you
go man I'm man I'm [__]
[__] all right Esther how about this the
idea of the submissive
female
why I mean sometimes I want to be
submissive I do it on purpose like
sometimes I'm a
switch I don't think anything wrong of
that the submissive do you understand
the stereotype mhm like you're supposed
to like do everything that a man tells
you to do right yeah but like it's
mostly asan sometimes it's hot sometimes
it's hot I like her but that's sometimes
they're thinking all the time more like
it being a stereotype that every woman
should every Asian woman is like that
that's why white men have like yellow
fever I don't even look at white men
so a
queen we got a win we got a win here
yeah no way Jose that should not be yeah
that should be on the list yes got it
you should be on the list or get get rid
of it oh it should be on the list of
getting out okay oh it's on the out list
okay emasculated male I think
that's Point At You Out of there's like
eight people here you were looking at me
already I think it's cuz me and Bart are
super I'm giving a microphone I'm
holding a giv me P for being B yeah I'm
pretty emasculated yeah so leave it in
that's the small dick thing you were
talking about though is it you want to
leave that in oh no no no yeah get rid
of that one you can live with that one
I'm already married Bro she's locked in
dude she's [__] locked she already
knows how small it
is wait don't you guys want people
thinking that so then when you show it
they're not disappointed actually they
might be more disappointed wait what
small I see they're saying under promise
overd deliver that's true cuz if they
expect this and wait wait wait why did
this go to dick size it always goes to
dick size man it's always about dick
size I think all I think all 10 of these
are about dick size I I I view that a
little differently same what a masculine
male yeah just like people expect Asian
men to almost along the same lines of
like submissive women and and uh uh
model minorities that they can just punk
you basically yeah cuz we're naturally
like smaller in stature and uh blah blah
blah mhm and also people are just more
Cal and respectful like I I feel like
Asian people they mistake kindness for
weakness they don't know the kindness
but when you when you are Asian I feel
like Asian culture is very traditional
so I feel like the men are far more
masculine than a lot of other cultures
this is true I mean my wife says the
same thing she's like you know British
from Wales and [__] she goes you know
what she goes I think as you have a
British wife yeah and then she's like
thank you very much thank you very much
vit loves white girls I don't know if
you can tell yo look I like them all but
she goes after like dating a I wasn't
the first Asian she dated she goes after
dating a lot of Asian guys she goes you
guys are actually very masculine but
where the West gets it wrong is they
just look at the surface so you look
young you look like you know um maybe
like not like all rugged and hairy and
[__] no facial hair no right but you're
like but the way y'all treat your
families your women the way you take
care of [__] the way that like you
basically run stuff and it's like she's
like that's very masculine and she goes
if we get a divorce I'm probably going
to get with another Asian guy yeah yeah
but that's what I mean it's like like in
the real sense of masculinity like I
think Asian culture like breeds more
masculine men but we just don't have
beards like that's it the only that's
the only thing missing yeah and the
large hog what about the idea this is an
interesting One Number Eight is the
unemotional or duplicitous friend do you
know what that is what's duplic I don't
know what that means I hate nextar cuz
they be they be just trying to flex for
no reason like you could have said that
so much better and you just chose that's
a $10 word they just be like vocab
flexing I have complex you know what I
you know what I think that means though
is um okay so like Latin or like white
culture or whatever right they express
emotions different from the way we do it
so they think we're unemotional because
we don't say I love you 24/7 and touch
each other all the time so then yeah
it's different right like we'll take
care of each other in a different way we
say I love you in a different way we
things like make sure that you're in the
will oh they're just talking about
Koreans duplicitas is treacherous
Behavior oh Koreans wao whoa whoa wait
are you Korean yeah I'm just
kidding he's like pick a new one oh
they're talking about Koreans so so
they're saying we're Too Faced
treacherous I think so I think what it
means you know how like in the old
Cinema they used to depict Asians as
such one dimensional characters that
clearly had like no depth to them it's
that it's like in the in the real world
they still see some Asians like that
I've been tricked by some Chinese
dudes did y'all know did y'all know
Koreans actually had the
longest don't bring up talking longest
brain of of slavery yeah really hey we
we number one at
everything congrats congrats you guys
that's awesome you guys should talk
about it more I'll take full
responsibility for that all that's not
on the list so I guess it's not that bad
of a problem uh number nine is the bad
driver that's not fair that's only
Chinese Honestly though like I kind of
think it's a little true sometime
sometimes it be coming out when I
driving and like somebody cuts me off
and I look at them I'm like of course
you're Asian and then I keep it moving I
also think though that that's one of
those generational things with
immigrants that's true agree cuz check
this out yeah where does Initial D come
from not bad driving also when you go to
places like Japan like where public
transportation works yeah we're just
[__] jealous over here that public
transport doesn't work so you have to
drive your whole life so you kind of get
good at one thing but we have poor
public transportation yeah you're right
we're just not complaining about that
category cuz most most of the bad Asian
drivers I see are older so is it an old
thing or is it Asian thing I agree with
the generation I actually think that
they're so good cuz I've been to Vietnam
and nobody follows the rules and there's
noci Asia bro that's true yeah yeah put
scooters on the roads here and let's see
we get some more accidents they're so
good there's no there's no accidents
Orin and everything but that's why when
you come into a stru driving country
like America and they're just driving
like it's still Vietnam and then like
the American drivers are like what the
[__] you're Breaking All the Rules but
they're like this is how I learned to
drive like there was no lines back also
in America it's like everybody's like
There Are Rules so then they they have
this entitlement as everyone's going to
follow the rules which is why there's an
accident every day on the freeway they
go hey buddy you're not supposed to do
that but then our buddy like [__]
dong or something he's like get the hell
out of the way man and then he's like
scooting by Americans are not good
defensive drivers yeah oh that's true
that's true when you go to like when I
was driving El Salvador they're all
really good defensive D they have no
[__] lights and they're just [__]
they got good D good D bro ni real good
number 10 is the Primitive villager
that's the idea that if you're Asian
then you have like backwards beliefs or
you have like what the [__] yeah that
you have uh that like you know like get
water from a well or some
[__] archaic archaic is this about like
Traditional Values kind of yeah I that
sounds like some old W wives tale [__]
like where we be like like a lot of
Asians do think like this though well
cuz like you let's say you have cultural
customs and to you it's like there's a
value in that but then to a person that
doesn't understand they're just like why
do you do that like why you they're like
this isn't the modern way yeah there's
no ghost here you know like that whole
idea where you just get uh scrutinized
for like having isn't that just racist
ignorance dude that's wild well yeah
that's kind of why isn't that what white
people love though they love [__]
fway and [__] they eventually do they
eventually do hey right now right now
they're hella about that Jade [__] and
crystals bro crystals they can't talk if
they're talking about crystals all the
time got don't they call like [__]
acupuncture now drying whatever that's
what they call it so it's just like Okay
thousands of years of cultural tradition
let's just rename it and then call it a
western thing yeah the first time I got
Dred I'm like what the [__] this just
acupuncture dude yeah let's call it
better
Boba salty better needling I don't I
don't
care ASMR is just Zam budhism
oh yeah what do you think is if you just
had to get rid of one of these what do
you think's the worst one at all the
none of them's bad they're not none of
them are that bad I'm picking the the
the the masculine the what is it the
ululated yeah I like that it works for
you in your yeah because then that's
they if you're a normal guy they go wow
you're such a [__] masculine Asian
dude usually Asian guys are [__]
[__] but you you're to hear that and
then I'm just like hey I don't have to
work so hard go through I I think
personally it benefits but I've also
seen like the the results of dudes who
feel like they they have no they can't
do anything about it they're like oh the
world just sees me this way anyways I
might as well just I give up like you
know what I'm saying and it's like sad
cuz a lot of people don't think like oh
well this is my opportunity to stand out
they're just like it's like
self-fulfilling prophecy cuz you care
about that and I'm greedy and I'm like
less competition now now I get the he's
for the greater good it's like Esther
said about the small dick thing it's
like if you never show anyone your dick
they're not going to know yeah stay
unless you walk around and show
everybody your feel the energy though
you know all right here's all 10 ready
you as soon as you hear the one that's
cut you have to like say it that's the
one I I can only pick one again you can
only pick one model minority Perpetual
Foreigner yellow
Peril Co starter I like that one dog cat
eater submissive female nah I don't like
that one that's the one that goes do
even a plat
we or Gio that's how you find it I think
the most actually the most harmful one
is the Foreigner one because they don't
feel like you're the same team so there
you go like oh you're a [__] you
[__] Chinese Communist coming into my
country trying to buy up all the
farmland and [__] spy on me [__] too
late it's too late you already picked it
I can't take it back I do agree with
that though yeah yeah I'm still picking
the masculine male one mhm I'm picking
bad drivers
dude he's like I'm nice at driving yeah
we're pretty good dude I know how to
drift
[Music]